What seems to be the
problem, Charlie Brown?
I haven't completed any of my
New Year's resolutions.
Good grief.
Your grandma didn't come
for Christmas this year
and Lucy took it pretty hard.
She thought it was
because of her.
You are loveable
and I know just how to prove it.
I'm going to throw a party,
and you're going to help.
What did I just get myself into?
Everyone should dress up,
be on time,
and good manners only.
Elegant perfection.
No one is having fun.
[Screams]
Charlie Brown,
how do you manage
to keep going
when life gets you down?
No matter how bad
things may seem,
I can always rely on my friends.
♪ Should old acquaintance ♪
I'm not sure if we're
doing it justice.
I wrote some of my own.
♪ One thing should never be
forgot Lucy's party
blew my mind ♪ Really?